Protocols and extensions are both
tools Swift uses to package modules of
functionality that expand upon classes,
enumerations and structs.
Protocols can be shared
across classes and
extensions are used to
customize existing classes.
They both provide ways to reuse code and
adhere to the principle
of dry programming.
That is to say, don't repeat yourself.
Let's focus on protocols for the moment.
If you're familiar with Java or C#,
you may have heard of interfaces before.
A protocol, much like an interface,
is a list of related method signatures.
When a Swift class enumeration or
struct adopts a protocol,
they're signing a contract to implement
every method belonging to said protocol.
This provides us a very powerful
high level abstraction.
For example, we can reason.
Anything that conforms to Apple's
built-in comparable protocol can be
compared.
And iOS development,
protocols are an essential
component of the delegate pattern,
the pattern by which one type calls upon
another type to perform some operation.
For a deeper dive into
the delegate pattern,
follow the links in
the instructor's notes.
Here, we're going to focus on
the syntax of defining, adopting, and
implementing protocols.